throw tab here a 14-year veteran in the
National Football League longtime Los
Angeles Rams Pro Football Hall of Fame
in 2001 and one of our favorites Jack
Youngblood good to see you jack how are
Chris it's always good to be with you
good to see you man you everything good
with you jack
oh well for an old man okay so let me
just ask you this
right off the bat jack seeing the Rams
back in Los Angeles last year what did
that what did that do for your just
watching that that was good from the
heart it really was to see him come back
it saddened me somewhat from four we've
got a lot of friends and family and st.
Louis and we caught we called hell to be
to be honest sure about that but they
belong back in LA that's us they they
burden Cleveland they came came to LA
and we established that you know that
franchise there and so seeing them back
in LA but not winning a lot of folks
were wondering if there's any they're
there for fans in Los Angeles
so it's this year you could you got to
say there's a big year for the Rams huge
a huge I I went to mr. Kroenke and told
him I said in a conversation
this is great for the bottom line I mean
your your your franchise now went from
what one to two to three
you know trillion billion I should say
yeah billion i but if you don't win
you're going to find crickets up there
and it's going to be hard to you know to
promote the franchise if you don't have
a good football team Jack young but here
in the Rich Eisen show in Canton Ohio
why do you come back to Kent what do you
do well you seem to be here every single
year Jack what he did I missed one I was
having some some health issues and back
in what was that 1213 and and it was a
killer because I had I had to sit in the
hospital room and watch this right that
was that was a heartbreaker for me this
is such an unique group
guys that it's hard to explain guys that
have done things in there they all have
the athletic aspects to them and we know
that I mean you have to have that to
even qualify but then you've got the
quality of people that are here that
have the dedication and have the
integrity to play the game at the
highest level for long periods of time
in this special group in Louisville and
we get to we get to visit with them once
a year and and reconnect and find out
you know what who's had who's had some
some stainless steel putting the body
and black all on a bill right past year
and how the families are and and the
girls
our wives who are so supportive of us
they've they've connected now they've
got their own little deal good right and
they don't they don't want to miss it at
all so it's uh it's just too sad to do
is to side of the coin and do you guys
talk about here with Jack Youngblood
here in the Rich Eisen show about your
brains I mean do you guys compare notes
on how you're feeling on your memory
your memory loss I know you're you're
somewhat integral in making sure that
this is at the forefront of the NFL's
mindset as well as the Players
Association here you've been doing a lot
of work on that front Jack so I'd love
to give you the floor on what you guys
talked about about that we really we
really have that concerns especially
last week everybody saw that the two
studies came that came out of Boston
University and the autopsies that proved
that CTE is something that's real and
it's a devastating illness and we don't
know a whole lot about it and we're
trying to you know we're trying to work
those studies to where we can we we can
you know they doctors want more and more
and more and more information because of
the liability that they have when they
you know have the information so we're
trying to to promote the league yes to
get behind that for years and years and
years you know in Roger don't like what
I'm going to say but they they've
ignored us we've had we had car crashes
and the league was responsible for the
car crash and now we've got damaged
bodies
we've got damaged vehicles that need to
be repaired as much as possible as much
as anything that's out there and that
responsibility is for the league so what
is the answer money help monetary help
monetary certainly helps because you can
you can bit there's things I'm involved
with the therapy that that offsets the
symptoms of concussions the memory the
[Music]
your emotions all of that is connected
to what we did to ourselves for years
and years and years in bowl games would
you trade that though no knowing knowing
God gave me this ability to do this and
and at that level yes and once you have
that responsibility to use that talent
you want to go you want to go and play
check in but here on the Rich Eisen show
how much quieter is it without Deacon
here oh my goodness
hahaha we were just talking about were
you really yeah yeah they can end and
right we lost to that had such passion
Ray Nitschke its radius connects me
so in this luncheon that you're named
after ray look he can took it over right
pretty on chef yeah when when Ray had
backed out you know and was unhealthy at
the end there big took over and if there
wasn't anybody in the world it's got
more passion for the for the game of
football concept quarterback star Jack I
mean he literally had an animus towards
quarterbacks
I think we all know Joey
hahahahahahahaha but he's like it would
literally it would legitimately pissed
Deacon off if there were multiple
quarterbacks in a qualifying class like
he could understand that quarterbacks uh
you know get the attention but when
there would be two in one class yeah
that really I didn't set well with it I
really pissed him off you know it really
really did and I you know I just always
enjoyed being around him and talking
what was it like when you came in to the
Rams was he was he there he had just
left where he was no it was there he was
there I am I I'm not my first flight out
I'm thinking okay you know where am I
going here I was the Twitter picked in
the first round how to flow 71 run out
of Florida didn't know the Los Angeles
Rams from from anything and did a little
homework and I'm going okay they're
speaking Jones Martin Olsen rosey Grier
and Lamar Lindy it's going to be a short
trip I think they will send me back home
in a hurry how do you how do I fit into
this group of guys of course Lamar and
MOSI had had left and and then I got
there and thanked good lord
someplace in that first year Merlin and
Deacon vote at some point in time put
their arm around me and said kid you can
play but we've got to teach you how to
play and I said well trust me I'm all
eyes in there he and I used to I used to
study I I wouldn't study the the
upcoming ball game I'd study deacons
games and how he handled a certain
tackle film how did film know and I
tried my best to emulate everything he
did and they welcomed you with open arms
Misha Lee or eventually or was there
some observing rookie sergeant just
openly in you know embrace what was in
blow today how did they age in it
I mean what did they do to make you do
it you have to carry bags you have to do
that sort of stuff general
I carry I cured Merlin beacons bag I had
two of them right you better take him
yeah take but but that's that was our
responsibility we're rookies we're
trying to take somebody's job and that
that's official you know to some guys I
would think you know then and I tried I
after being there ten years I tried to
get coaches to bring me somebody that I
could mentor to fill the gap because I
didn't have anybody behind me Jack
Youngblood here in the Richardson show
what was the number that von Miller said
Brockman Denver sax that he thinks is
possible you have von Miller thinks he
can get 30 sacks 15 Jake who do you
think 33 0 in a season NFL record 22 and
a half well it depends on who he's
playing if he's if he's playing the
Cowboys I don't think he's going to get
that number if he plays them twice I
don't think you know that's going to
happen they got some pretty good players
there so that's a that's a big that's a
big achievement what do I mean before
that stack as sack wasn't a stat until
1982 right did you ever do you ever have
close to 30 in a season
no you think two seasons over huge
diseases you have 30 I had 151 over the
course of 14 what who's counting I know
I know even though it wasn't a stat just
yet even though but the crazy part about
that is that they paid before what do
you mean hey I was a that with the bonus
how many had if you had to get to five
and then the bonus kicked in and then
there was additional you know it's like
$1,000 back then was that what it was
yeah it should be taken if you got five
so I got five I'd get a thousand extra
because I wasn't making but 21 $21,000
here other people are going he's lying
to us
okay that's fake news now is it is it
true that you would you have a smoke
break during the game did that happen no
no no never during a game they will
never do a ball game no yes you guys are
advised against the deal okay that is it
again
yeah but before and after you but before
and after I I did have that the heater
yeah I did
it's okay and I know it's embarrassing
though it because I knew better and I
shouldn't have been doing that yeah but
people were that mean it's just
different times well in John Jack I was
a workout freak I mean I never wanted to
be out of condition and have an
offensive lineman had the edge of me in
the fourth quarter I mean I was a
conditioned that was one of the main
things I did in the offseason and last
one for what was it like being in Los
Angeles playing for the Rams in the 70s
and and you know Sinatra being around
the team on occasion Don Rickles and all
that what was that like it was it was
eye-opening for for a country boy from
University of Florida the Panhandle and
in Florida and it had not been past the
Mississippi yeah yeah and I'm flying
into LA and I'm thinking oh my goodness
gracious laughs okay what is going on
here I'd never seen a city that big you
know you you approach landing an hour
out Yeah right that sure and it was it
was a total I was walking around in are
looking up at the big buildings then and
smog and and then going into the locker
room you know I have remembered this up
landing and I'm thinking the thought
came across I said well under what
number I'm all I'm gonna get and I was
standing thinking we wouldn't be nice to
you know playing in 74 that was my
number in Gainesville and Florida and I
walk into the locker room and the first
thing I saw literally the first thing I
saw hanging right on the front of the
locker was number 74 Olson he I went
well that's enough of that
that's enough of that
yeah Merlin wasn't going to call fit-up
no he would Jack always love chat with
you love having on the show love having
you by love swapping stories and it's
always great to see Richard we love you
but thanks bye thank you miss that is
Jack Youngblood Pro Football Hall of
Famer year on the Rich Eisen show sir
Rich Eisen shown weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like some of
that get some more of that on the Rich
Eisen shell app follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show